I can just see your little businesses
being crushed I predicted your 401 kids
we're gonna evaporate didn't I didn't
die but I thought I knew we were going
to have a tsunami but I didn't know it
was gonna be Corona I thought it was
going to be the federal deficit I knew
that the collapse and oil price would
exacerbate it whatever it was and now me
saying oil is going to go to $5 doesn't
sound so funny does it you have no idea
how much [ __ ] I took about that fight
out of oil
we may get negative oil in other words
they pay you to take it off their hands
negative interest rates aren't the only
thing they can go negative kids right
now the US government is buying up or
the put in the strategic reserve so what
but President Trump only has so many
arrows in his quiver he's owned there's
only so many things he can do
none of which save the little companies
that you're gonna be buying we may wipe
out a whole section of the world economy
a whole section and just remember at the
end of World War 1 at the end of World
War two guys got rich but there were
ruthless and savage decisions to be made
this is still another bubble now if I
were the president this is the greatest
time to get rid of the deficit and by
the way sticking a trillion dollars in
the economy doesn't mean a goddamn thing
it needs to be a thousand trillion
dollars we don't have a thousand
trillion dollars if we printed a
thousand trillion dollars in America it
would be hyperinflation a dollar be
worth a nickel
and I tell you all this this [ __ ] do
give you the gravity of how exceptional
the opportunities are I know that there
are businesses that are being shut down
and companies going out of business
because of the coronavirus and it's very
unfortunate and this is why has an
entrepreneur we always need to be
prepared maybe now it's a time to look
at what you do in we structure your
business a bit maybe switching some of
the employees to independent contractors
maybe there are certain functions in the
business then you could outsource maybe
it's also time to consider having a more
window team maybe most structure so when
things like this happen and will happen
again that it will not be what effective
business but it will not destroy your
business also maybe consider not just
having businesses that are maybe all
events driven using the online using the
technology using certain tools to be
able to keep your business going I think
that's also pretty important I dad used
to tell me story he was 14 in 1918 and
they told me what went on in Omaha you
know during the big Spanish flu epidemic
I mean it was it was something in those
days and and pandemics will occur in the
in the future now what they hope to get
is a universal flu vaccine but that's a
long way off it isn't impossible I mean
I asked my my own science advisors Bill
Gates so I talked to him I call him I
talked him the last few days about about
it and he's bullish on the long term
outlook for a universal prevention of it
but but so they're not going to come in
offered they're not gonna be here in ten
years what our water bills concerns as
somebody who spends a lot of time
traveling around the globe as somebody
who
trying to help medicine in some of the
less develop art of the world yet the
Gates Foundation is is very active and
trying to be helpful on this and and
Bell says the CDC is the best in the
world and I mean we've got terrific
resources in this country but a pandemic
is a pandemic and and there's just no
evaluating and but I have heard that the
summer is not likely to cause the end of
this do you know why but I don't know
and you know you shouldn't be I should
be offering my opinion on it because I I
pass along things right here from people
I think are smart but but I'm actually
asking for Bill's opinion not yours
I shouldn't it shouldn't really quarter
but I do I
he's the guy I asked I and I didn't talk
to was just a few days ago
and he loves to talk science and he
could make it so I could understand it
which is quite a trick you know at the
Gates Foundation they're taking it very
seriously I'll put it that way what is
the last time you got the flu or got a
cold or got sick where you were out for
a while do you remember the last time
it's not bad you're doing cold training
often you're leading retreats every
other week you're climbing you know a
mountain and snow and freezing cold
shirtless you're jumping in freezing
rivers cold tubs ice showers you're
doing these things but you don't
remember the last time you got sick
maybe a little little here and there but
you were able to get yourself back to
the full power are you and this time
staying at home and making sure you're
protecting yourself and the ones around
you even though you're trained to not
get sick or are you saying you know I'm
gonna go outside I'm gonna live my life
I'm gonna touch everything and touch my
mouth and I'm not worried what's your
mindset during this time I'm absolutely
not in fear related to coronavirus
infection I know how to be too
to beat it I know how to prayer to spy
got my immune system
I know this I already talked to the
University and I told her hey guys you
got still got my blood my beat taken
while I was doing my exercises and that
blood has shown to be a resistant
against a bacteria
injected into the blood normally there
is an aggressive reaction of the immune
cells ex-vivo in laboratory setting so
without me but it's my blood and I and
they took it when I was doing my
exercising and they took it for me there
is a very violent reaction on the in
users now they took my blood and I put
in the same bacteria and there was zero
reaction on the image really zero zeros
this whistles I told him yes all of our
researches were absolutely any virus not
what creates inflammation and rotavirus
also just a creates inflammation so we
were not able to bring down inflammation
as well and I showed how to bring it
completely down so at least let them
investigate how this is possible because
I've been showing it and then they told
me you are the only one who is able to
do this because you are the Iceman then
I directly said no give me a group of
people and I will show you just in a
couple of days how to bring them to the
autonomic nervous system the image
immune system how to bring down
inflammation and then you test them all
with a bacteria you inject them and
cause in flamish in in the body the
innate immune system reaction and then
you will see they all will break down
that in contrary of hundreds and
thousands of people who have done the
same experiment and all got sick Wow CPA
training I'm I'm a father for happy and
all that stuff this coronavirus has got
me thinking about like making a change I
just don't know really to what you know
like I could keep doing what I'm doing
I'm gonna be 50 next year I'm I'm very
dedicated to like self-improvement I
listen to all your stuff like I'm very
happy to be talking to you but at the
same time like I'm now like what's next
and so that's that's the question is
like how do you what advice would you
give to somebody who is facing this sort
of situation where it's like okay well
what do I do for the next step because
I've I've had a moment in my life or
where I've had the opportunity to
reflect yeah so you need to take some
time to play so a lot of people have a
sense okay somebody's not right with my
life it's not all that it could be but
they don't know where they want to go
and there's not literally nothing to do
but play until you know where you want
to go so you need to figure out what
world of things do you want to be around
so it because it may be that simple
right it may be I'm gonna stay being a
CPA but I'm gonna do it in you know for
a company that is something that I care
deeply about it's just things that I
want to be around you know for me it's
movies video games comic books that kind
of stuff so if I had a whole nother
skill set maybe I would go do that in
that world or it may be that no you
totally want to reinvent yourself and
you don't mind starting low man on the
totem pole cool whatever it is first you
need to identify what that universe is
so that you can get pointed in the right
direction and if you don't know what
that is either you're not being honest
with yourself and you do know your areas
of interest
remember there's not going to be a
hidden passion there's just going to be
unacknowledged areas of interest go and
engage with one of those areas or if
truly nope I really don't know
it isn't me that I secretly know and I
just don't want to admit I really don't
know then go play like go explore do a
bunch of different stuff take classes
online like find out what is that thing
that gives you more energy than it takes
and for me the easiest way and this
definitely is me painting with my
worldview but I always ask myself what
is it that I want to be the best in the
world at and there's nothing more
intoxicating for me than going alright
this is a puzzle for me to solve and I'm
gonna go and figure this out better than
anybody else and I get intoxicated by
that notion of like I so don't have an
ego about this and I know that I'll be
so much more nimble than everybody else
because I'm I'm willing to be honest
with myself about whether or not I'm
making progress and I know most people
can't do that's crazy the number of
people that invest and being right or
being smart and I just don't invest like
that so I invest in learning and so I
just end up outperforming other people
and because I so love that process of
winning of learning more learning faster
being more efficient more effective it's
like even if I end up failing I so love
trying to solve that puzzle that I I
just have a great time doing that and so
my obsession around sincere pursuit
right so I'm gonna sincerely pursue
whatever maybe you want to go be a
professional bass fishery scar driver in
the fifty and over circuit like whatever
it doesn't matter what that thing is but
it's like really getting into a place
where it's like hey this is the thing I
want to fail at doing this is the thing
I want to spend the next twenty years
struggling at ultimately fail if you can
say that sentence to be like this is the
thing I want to do you can't lose you
can't lose and then if you're sincerely
pursuing the win then it's like hey you
might actually win because you're not
boasting yourself you're not lying you
don't need to win for it to be a win if
that makes sense it's it's the pursuit
it's the love of that thing it's being
immersed in that world it's finding a
way to add meaning and purpose to the
pursuit of that thing right that's a
process you're just gonna decide I'm
here to serve this person that matters
to me whatever you gonna say that out
loud again check out my mindset 101
class which I think we solve the link up
I can see more but so that that is huge
going through that recognizing that is a
process that you won't turn
and find a passion you won't turn inward
and find a passion right so passion is
not an archaeological dig it is an
architectural build and it's going down
that process of building that passion in
your life so it's going to start with
play if you want more advice wisdom
guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there when your life has
that moment of a down drop
[Music]